alex smith not done playing football but
clearly is done playing for the
washington football team i already
thought they were going to cut him
shireen and it dawned on me last week
the bears make the most sense for alex
smith because he knows matt nagy knows
the offense 19 million is the
compensation package this year for alex
smith here's what he said
in an interview with gq
when i decided to come back i definitely
threw a wrench in the team's plan
washington football team 2020. they
didn't see it didn't want me there
didn't want me to be a part of it didn't
want me to be on the team the roster
didn't want to give me a chance mind you
it was a whole new regime they came in
i'm like the leftovers and i'm hurt and
i'm this liability heck no they didn't
want me there at that point as you can
imagine everything i've been through i
couldn't have cared less about all that
whether you like it or not i'm giving
this a go at this point you may ask
yourself why in the hell was he even on
the team then if they didn't want him
his salary was guaranteed for last year
injury guarantee they weren't getting
out from under it he didn't pass a
physical before it became fully
guaranteed that's why he was still there
and i love this aspect of the story this
is a great final 20 minutes of the movie
that inevitably will be produced how
he's hell bent to come back and play and
at every turn
washington football team officials are
like damn it oh really really this guy
really we have to play this guy real we
want to move on we want to we want to
lay the foundation for the future and
they get to the playoffs with alex smith
i just think that that part of it's
awesome but it tells me he will be cut i
feel even more strongly about this one
he will be cut before march 17 shireen
yeah i have no doubt mike and it
certainly sounds like he wants to
continue his career he'll be 37
in may but he proved he can come back
and he proved that he can be a starting
quarterback in this league now i don't
know that he goes somewhere that he can
start chicago perhaps and compete with
nick foles as you said that makes the
most sense simply because he does know
that offense but i do see washington
moving on from him i mean you've seen
all the signs of this and you look at
what it took actually for him to play
last year i mean we said well it's a
success that he's even made the roster
right and then he finally gets on the
field in in week five i think it was we
said oh what a success he's won comeback
player of the year he's gotten on the
field but you know it took dwayne
haskins being bench kyle allen being
injured for alex smith even to get his
chance he goes five and one as a starter
the stats weren't great i mean he had
more interceptions than he had
touchdowns and he ranks near the bottom
of every category there but you know it
was a successful story there's no
question about that with leading them to
the playoffs and then he doesn't get to
play the playoff game because tyler
hinkey starts that game because alex
smith is hurt with that calf injury so
washington ended up starting four
quarterbacks last year mike i know
they'd like to find some stability at
that position alex smith is not who
they're looking for and i'm with you i
think they move on from alex smith and
alex smith plays another year somewhere
else
do you think that that they're
interested in cam newton in washington
with the presence of ron rivera and
marty herney or was nine years enough
for both sides in carolina
well they had a chance to do it last
year right and they didn't do it and i
don't know maybe they've seen enough in
new england to think well we bring them
back we know they're in on all these
quarterbacks they definitely want an
upgrade at the starting quarterback
position they're gonna have tyler henke
back we know that kyle allen more than
likely comes back so they're gonna have
those two guys back and then you add the
veteran on top of that and i think they
think especially the division they're in
mike that they can win with whoever they
start at quarterback but they can't win
a super bowl with whoever they start at
quarterback it's got to be an upgrade
over what they had last year
and cert to me cam newton certainly is
an upgrade over what they had at
quarterback last year when you consider
all the different quarterbacks they
started mike
yeah i agree with you and uh that's just
another example of why this offseason is
going to be so crazy every team taking a
step back it seems like other than a
small handful and saying what do we have
a quarterback what are we going to do
who else is out there it's unprecedented
to this degree and it may be the new
normal
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports